and coming up next on bbc one will be
nothing
[Music]
hey there folks this is gonna be uh
gonna be one of those odd topics that i
didn't think i was gonna have anything
to say about
but
somebody asked actually in the premiere
chat uh for the last video that went up
if i was going to talk about this at all
and at the time i said yeah i don't
think so but then i started thinking
about it and then i started looking into
it and then i'm like
yeah maybe and that's what's going on at
the bbc with its funding or rather the
cutting off of its current funding model
if that uh actually goes through
now part of me wanted to be like that's
not really my wheelhouse to talk about
except
it kind of is
i've talked about big moves and
shake-ups at companies like warner
brothers when they gutted dc or when
disney acquired fox so i've talked about
these kinds of things before when it
comes to entities particularly ones that
are related in some way to things i
otherwise talk about and well
i talk about doctor who a lot now i'm
not really going to be filtering this
through a discussion of doctor who in
specific i'm going to be talking about
the topic in the broad terms
part of the reason i was nervous to talk
about this and this is also sort of my
caveat upfront to try and give myself a
little bit of wiggle room
i don't
inherently
know
as much about the bbc and its funding
model as i do about say
corporate entities like disney or warner
brothers to put it simply
living and working in america and having
worked at
various levels and interacted with all
levels of a corporate structure in the
u.s has given me
way more knowledge of how these things
work and how these entities tend to
think than i would honestly like to have
but the bbc while it is a corporation
technically it is publicly funded so
my normal understanding of the
keep pushing profit at all costs
maximize income
in whatever way can do it doesn't really
apply here because the way they get
their funding was
fixed and it wasn't something that they
actually
could adjust to bring in more money so
the it's a bit of a different beast and
since i'm not myself from the uk i have
had to look a lot of this stuff up and
there might be holes in my research or
there might just be background things
that aren't even in the kind of things i
researched that you would just know for
living there that i don't so i honestly
feel like this is probably going to be
more helpful to people in my situation
who don't live in the uk i have a strong
feeling i'm going to get more than a few
comments from my uk viewers because i
know there's a decent number of you on
things i missed or got wrong or what
have you i'm still going to do my best
i'm not using that as an excuse to be
lazy about this i'm going to try and
cover this topic as best and as
thoroughly as i'm able to just
understand i'm working with a handicap
on this one
more so than is normally the case on any
time i talk about something that isn't a
standard topic for me so that out of the
way
what is going on with the bbc
well
they're kind of screwed
or at least it's looking that way right
now so uh the short version is that
nadine doris who is the culture
secretary
in the uk has done
two things one she has announced a
freeze on the bbc licensing fee if you
don't know what that is don't worry i'll
get to it but she's announced a freeze
on it so that it will not increase over
the next two years now
that might just sound like okay so
they're not going to raise the cost to
the general public for
the you know what they use to fund the
bbc what's the problem with that well
with the current state of inflation and
where that's expected to go that's
basically looking at effectively a two
billion dollar budget cut to the bbc but
more importantly she has said that they
plan to end that funding scheme at the
end of the current royal charter the
royal charter being the current stretch
of time under which uh things are
supposed to operate as they currently
are and after which they can then be
changed into a different model or
theoretically dropped completely now
that ends on the last day of 2027. so
right now there's a ticking clock
that after which the bbc
may not exist anymore or at least not in
the form it currently is in
and has been in for a very very long
time now again for folks who aren't from
the uk i should explain the licensing
fee as i said the bbc is publicly funded
now the closest thing we have in the u.s
is something like the national endowment
of the arts or the corporation for
public broadcasting but that's a little
bit different and kind of weird around
here because that funds certain national
efforts to have these things like uh
public radio and pbs uh the tv channel
running but
the individual local channels have to do
their own regional funding it's why you
always see the pledge drives or hear
them on the radio for those sorts of
things local stations
are kind of on their own for most of
their funding um and
the national endowment for the arts in
the us is something that has been a bit
of a political football for well longer
than i've been alive actually it's still
in place but it ain't much the way the
bbc does it the licensing fee
is basically
well
you have to have a license to get
tv
broadcast from the bbc is how that works
so
what that means is while they can't
actually prevent you from receiving bbc
television signals whether it was back
in the day where you could pick it up on
uh just on the local broadcast or
whether it be now with it coming as
standard channels but
if you're getting that in your home you
are supposed to be paying a licensing
fee to be able to have that now this
started
back in
1946
post-war
and initially adjusted for inflation was
significantly cheaper but that's because
when the funding for that started it was
for one channel in black and white in
the 60s they introduced separate fees
for getting black and white signal
or getting color so basically whether
you had a color or a black and white
television set with the color being more
expensive now
once they implemented that
the
raw number for what it cost
has been going up steadily
however adjusted for inflation it's kind
of been up and down all over the place
the fee has not always kept pace with
inflation which is now what's going to
happen
because it's going to be frozen for the
next two years despite inflation going
to be increasing by by all indications
now the licensing fees was kind of a
roundabout way to do it because it
wasn't really a direct tax because
when it was implemented not everybody
had a tv so having literally everybody
pay this tax didn't make sense so
instead paying it on if you had a tv
and were getting those signals that was
who was going to pay it so in many ways
at least the initiation of the licensing
fee program is an outdated model or at
least it certainly started from a
completely different mentality than they
have now and there's some odd quirks in
the history of it like for a long time
the bbc claimed to have what they called
uh tv detector vans uh which could
detect whether or not a signal was being
received into a house that had not paid
his licensing fee and they would then
fine you
there's every indication that such a
thing never existed and was just a
propaganda thing to scare people into
paying their licensing fees now
licensing fee payments in general have
been going down
and most of that is chalked up to people
switching to streaming things like
netflix and other services of that
nature there's also possibly an increase
in just basically protests not willing
to pay it
you can get fined for that but i'm going
to kind of come back to that so the
angle to change or defund
or alter the way the funding is done for
the bbc or possibly get rid of licensing
fee altogether has generally been a push
from the conservative side
of uk politics now i'm gonna try to the
best of my ability not to get
overly political or at least not be
overly expressive of my own political
opinions in this some of it's gonna leak
through
i can't help that but that's the simple
truth the conservative side have been
the ones pushing for this boris johnson
had floated i think a couple of years
ago the possibility of making the
licensing fee voluntary which
which seemed very much at the time that
never happened by the way but that
seemed very much at the time to be
something to basically
slowly strangled the bbc to death
because
you know people if they didn't have to
pay it
why would they like some people would
but not enough to fund the dang thing
whereas now uh nadine dory's move just
seems to be no we're not gonna we're not
gonna do this slow death we're just
gonna kill it at the first available
date which is the end of the charter now
i kind of have to focus on nadine dory's
uh in specific because uh she's said
more than a few things over the last few
years that make her
angle on this
pretty clear
now a lot of this is stuff from twitter
and tweets from even a number of years
ago probably the most telling one was a
tweet where she said that left-wing
snowflakes were killing comedy now while
some of these tweets like i said date
from a couple years ago she's never
walked back any of this and about the
closest she's come she's tried to like
muddy the waters a little bit in terms
of how harsh and direct and like very
clear
that she was basically just complaining
about anything that
didn't align with the conservative
values that she held she was finding a
way to complain about she's tried to in
interviews
make it a little bit murkier that that
wasn't quite what she was doing
left-wing snowflakes and they're working
you know it's quite aggressive well
there are some people who will
politicize that and and that's what i'm
talking about when i do that and in fact
i want to talk about her recent tweet
where she kind of announced this entire
plan the days of the elderly being
threatened with prison sentences and
bailiffs knocking on doors are over now
first thing there that's
did that
happen yeah
kind of not much i looked up into the
statistics as best as i could find
because actually a lot of the law
enforcement and government entities
don't keep
proper track
of what happens in terms of warrants
issued or
arrests or fees or fines
related to failure to pay tv licensing
fees there's some data out there and
generally what the data points to is it
doesn't happen that much
not a lot not a lot of warrants are
requested to investigate this and only
about half of those are are granted and
not even all of those are actually
carried out and it also varies by region
scotland basically doesn't do this at
all most of it seems to happen in
england and uh second most in wales but
a lot of other parts of the uk don't
really seem to have that level of
enforcement at all so basically what
nadine dory's is doing there
is she's taking the most outlier extreme
cases of what can happen under the
current system
and presenting it as if it's something
that's happening all the time it's a
very common technique all sides of any
political debate use this a lot so it's
a very common technique but it's also
inherently by its nature deceptive and
as far as threats of prison
sort of but not exactly so so far as i
was able to find people don't actually
get jail time or get threatened with
jail time for not paying their licensing
fees
what they get threatened with jail time
for is failing to pay the fine for not
paying their licensing fees so it's like
a couple steps down the line
it's not like hey you didn't pay your tv
license fee go to jail it's hey you
didn't pay your tv license fee here's
the fine for that well i'm not gonna pay
this
we're gonna take you to court now you
will you pay the fine no i won't pay the
fine okay now we're gonna put you in
jail and that has happened again
very little with an average jail
sentence of about nine days uh from the
last year that i could find any kind of
data on that which was 2018. so it
wouldn't be fair to say that she is
making that up and that doesn't happen
at all because
technically it does but first of all the
association of having it happen to
elderly people is very specifically
targeted because conservative politics
generally appeal more to the elderly so
yeah that's pretty obvious but then
there's the other half of this which i
think is even more telling which is
where she says time to discuss and
debate new ways of funding now what's
funny to me about this is she has set an
end date for when the current funding
model for the bbc is going to end
and she says now it's time to discuss
and debate
a new funding model
meaning she doesn't have one
she's not coming in and saying we've got
a plan for how to do this better and
once we have all solidified what that is
we're gonna change it no she's saying no
we end it now and we'll talk about what
to do after that it reminds me a great
deal of what the republicans tried to do
with obamacare
under trump they were very fixated on
dismantling it as much as they possibly
could but at every step of the way they
didn't have a plan to replace it
and
they didn't really completely upend it
they did weaken it substantially from
what it was but they never really had a
replacement plan but they kept trying to
end it anyways very clearly the priority
not being we're going to stop this
because we have a better idea but we're
going to stop this because we hate it
maybe we'll come up with a better idea
if we can be bothered
so it is funny that it kind of rhymed
with that at least to my eye now
assuming this happens and does go
through
what happens to the bbc
well most likely they will look into
alternate funding methods i think it's
unlikely that there will simply
cease to be a bbc
um that's not a hundred percent
impossible
but i i find that to be the least likely
but it's definitely gonna have to change
from the ground up possible alternate
funding models would include things like
advertising part of the benefit of the
bbc being funded by the license fees
means that there is no advertising for
anything other than like what's on later
tonight on the bbc they don't have
corporate sponsors and advertisements
run on it now they could start doing
that
the problem there is
again streaming has really eaten into
the value of advertising and
basically unless you're uh buying a
super bowl ad spot
these companies aren't paying as much
for to run ads as they used to they're
just not because tv doesn't have the
stranglehold on the audience that it did
before the days of streaming so while
they could do that it would still
probably be looking at significant cuts
to their budget in order to do that
there is the possibility of setting up
some kind of netflix style service
um where people will basically not have
access to the bbc at all
unless they pay a subscription for it
now that differs from the licensing fee
because anyone who has a tv setup can
get the bbc they're supposed to have
paid their license in order to do that
but like they can technically get their
hands on it doing it as a subscription
model you could actually fully prevent
anyone who
hasn't paid for the subscription from
get well i mean to the extent that you
came with netflix people share their
passwords it happens but
um that's another option the problem is
it's really unclear how high the demand
is going to be for something like that
it's also going to make the bbc
far more
susceptible to having to
bow to the whims of what appeals to the
audience now that might sound like a duh
why shouldn't they appeal to the
audience but one can make the argument
at least especially from
an artistic and uh a news integrity
angle it's to the general benefit
that the bbc does not have to appeal to
audiences because it's funded whether
people like what's on it or not now
again if you don't like what's on it
that can be incredibly frustrating i do
not doubt that but broadly speaking that
enables it to do things that it feels
have artistic merit in terms of its
dramatic and entertainment programming
or that it feels are vitally important
in terms of its news programming without
having to worry about what the ratings
are now let's not say the bbc doesn't
keep track of the ratings they are but
they don't solely dictate things the way
they do when you have to keep your
audience happy or they'll leave and
won't pay the subscription fee and
suddenly you're not making anywhere near
as much money the instant that it
depends on a subscription model is the
instant that they have to
they have to alter everything they do in
the entire mentality of the bbc has to
go from we think this is uh
something worth doing we think this is
artistically valid and worth producing
to
will people like it and that's not again
that's not to say will people like it is
not some kind of factor but it doesn't
have to be the driving factor it would
have to become
the driving factor in that kind of model
which again
would represent a fundamental shift in
what the bbc is and how it does
anything that it does
and then there's the third option
which is direct funding from the
government as a budget item
now that might not sound particularly
different from the licensing fee because
isn't that still publicly funded
yes
but it makes the politics a lot more
fraught here's what i mean by that
because the bbc itself is empowered to
collect the fees and enforcement to the
best of its ability that means that
while the
nature of the fees the cost of the fees
whether they're allowed to go up
that
is to some degree controlled by the
government but the actual collection of
the fees is done by the bbc and if
everyone is paying their uh their tv
license that is supposed to be then
once the bbc has that that's just their
budget that they fail what to do with
if they start getting funded directly by
the government
then that means that the
whoever is in control of the government
can increase
decrease or threaten to do either one
in a way that will very substantively
affect
the programming
basically because the government would
have direct control of the purse
that the bbc would be funded from
it gives them more direct power to swing
the political perspectives of the bbc as
a whole and bbc news in specific now
that is kind of
flatly what some of them probably want
i'm not necessarily going to say nadine
dory specifically wants that but if she
is complaining about a quote-unquote
left-wing bias
in uh bbc programming and not even
limiting those complaints to the news
since she was complaining about comedy
then yeah that is the kind of mentality
that
you could see leading to someone
who if they had control of the funding
just going
stop making stuff with this perspective
or will cut your budget
now
to a certain extent
there is still already
uh political
control over the bbc but it's not direct
it is still a stage removed because of
the way the licensing fee works but it
is still there like i would not be
shocked if a lot of the stuff that tim
davey who is the current uh person
running the bbc if a lot of the stuff
he's been doing and saying particularly
around bbc news is not partially in the
hope of heading off this move
because a little while back
folks will remember
my issues with
the news arm of the bbc right now
there's a link to the original video
that i did talking about my issues with
a particular article which they have
continued to fail to acknowledge the
problems with it of all time it's not
just the transphobia also the outright
provable lies if you want more
information
beyond that um i'll put some links down
in the description to not only my video
but the now three videos that sean has
done on the topic as well as a terrific
speech from laura k dale who was part of
a protest outside the bbc offices but in
the wake of that one of the things tim
davey has now said uh in various very
questionable forms was to push the idea
of the bbc being
as objective and as neutral as possible
even going so far as to say if enough
members of the public expressed interest
he would give air time to flat earth
advocates
which is
absurd
the job of the news is to present the
truth
not to present all sides of an argument
when one side of that argument
has no merit
but he has been saying that stuff and
the fact that he's been saying that has
been
bizarre
and like almost memed in some cases
but it makes a lot more sense now that
we've seen
nadine dory's make her move and i would
not be shocked to learn that tim davey
did that and said those things
in the hope of trying to quell
this move from from someone like
nadine dory's knowing that this kind of
thing was coming or being discussed if
he was trying to push as loudly and
publicly as he could we don't have a
bias we are neutral look how neutral we
are we'll even let flat earthers come on
that's how neutral we are don't cut us
for being left wing but she's doing it
anyways
or at least she's planning to and that's
the last thing
we're looking at more than five years
down the line for this to fully take
effect so if there is a change in which
party is currently in control of the
government that's five years in which
this course can be altered and changed
and walked back and undone
so
that's also a possibility but you can
expect that
until such time as that happens at the
very least
those discussions about how do we fund
this then are still going to have to
happen
now
there's
too much
invested in the bbc not just financially
but culturally i think for them to just
let it die i don't think this is a case
of the tories actually want that's the
conservative part in the uk i don't
think they actually want the service
completely dead
they just want it to say
what they want to hear
and i think the
cultural and even political impact of
just letting the entire thing die
i don't think that would be good for
them and i think they know that
um at least that's sort of my outsider
view
i could be wrong about that i'm going by
the vibe i get and what makes sense to
me but i'm not on the ground in the uk
so what do i know as for the impact on
certain things in particular like say
doctor who i would actually say doctor
who is one of the things that is least
likely to be completely cut depending on
what happens i mean initially with the
several billion dollars lost just from
inflation and them not being allowed to
raise the fee
doctor who may be reduced in episodes
yet again that's a possibility but
doctor who is one of the bigger
properties for the bbc because it gets
licensed and
appears on services outside the uk
it's on hbo max and there was a deal cut
that hbo max paid to be able to do that
so like the big things that are well
known and well marketed outside the uk
like doctor who or even something like
the great british bake off those are the
things that are going to stay because
not only regardless of their specific
level of popularity in the uk itself
they will bring in significant money
from partnerships outside of the uk
so because of that they are kind of too
big to drop at least as it currently
stands it's one of the reasons why um
the things about the doctor who ratings
and why i haven't indulged that
conversation a long time
is that the ratings at this point are
not even secondary they're tertiary
because a lot of the revenue generated
by something like doctor who isn't even
directly from the show itself anymore
it's from
licensing it out and the value of being
able to do that is higher if there is
going to continue to be more new content
than if it's a dead thing that you know
you're just basically licensing out a
library of back uh episodes so
for that reason i i
don't i i have not indulged the the
ratings talk in a long time despite
being well aware ratings for
uh the chibnall era have
not been good especially
towards the end of it but there's also
been an overall decline
on viewers on views for bbc as a whole
again
streaming is a big part of that
so
there's certainly an argument to be made
that maybe it was time for the bbc to
evolve and to change
just because of how
old its funding model was does it even
make sense anymore but it's still really
troubling to me that the uh plan seems
to be
well let's definitely kill its current
state right now we'll figure out how to
change it later
anytime something gets approached that
way especially by politicians that's
gonna get an eyebrow raise and
from me
but again
outside of looking in
not my country
but that is the state of the bbc what
things look like now and where they may
or may not be going in the future to the
best of my ability to explain and even
understand
not being someone
actually down in the thick of it
what are your thoughts on all this any
of it how much did i get wrong
whatever your thoughts drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
i have a patreon if you wish to support
what i do and keep this whole operation
up and running the likes of shares and
subscribes they help me out as well
there's also links to my other stuff
twitch
tick tock
twitter all of that but
don't worry too much about it
because what i really want you to
remember
is that you're beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council
i'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council
is
[Music]
adjourned thanks for sticking around
into the credits none of this would have
been possible without my patreon
supporters in particular i want to thank
robin powell tracy scrabbit vincent paul
partolucci robin moore jayla gourle and
bookworm
thanks for keeping this going and to
everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]